hi everyone i'm alana and today i wanted
to
kind of make a director's commentary
sort of
seems like an odd way to phrase it for
whatever reason um of
the short film that i published on the
18th
of march it is called one year and it is
essentially just intended to be an
expression of
um an increasing sense of isolation
or an increasing sense of depression uh
first up it is a short film i got a lot
of comments and people being like wow i
wouldn't be this miserable if this was
my apartment
like stuff like that where i kept having
to be like hey this is scripted and
acted this is a short film this is not
my apartment my apartment is
much smaller and uh covered in a video
came memorabilia
no i actually very intentionally picked
an apartment that had a balcony that had
glass for specific shots that i wanted
and also that was like quite white um i
wanted a sort of
clinical look to it so yeah that was
location scouted
uh was very specific with the place that
we shot it but yes it is it is fully
scripted i wrote it
last year um it did originally have more
dialogue and it did have some character
development and i ended up
basically getting rid of all of that in
favor of trying to challenge myself more
because i have written three short films
that i
intend to make this year the others are
all narrative focused this one again
i wanted to just kind of make an
expression of a feeling it is a
visual representation of one feeling
that a lot of people felt last year i
imagine i was alone
in a studio apartment for six months and
i feel like i
did express something that i felt some
of the time
not all of the time obviously i had
happy moments
in my 2020 as well but some things worth
noting that are directly related to that
that i you know again
created challenges and was really
specific about it is exactly three
minutes and 11 seconds because that is
the
date being 311 um that we were declared
as to be in a pandemic in the united
states
um and then it was published on the 18th
of march because that
is one year of lockdown i also
was very specific about the length of
shots they're all intentionally quite
short
um and obviously
this first shot uh we can see
i committed what is considered kind of a
short film cliche
you're not allowed to start a short film
um on someone waking up to an alarm
clock which naturally
is what happens here i think this is a
five second shot maybe i made it a
little bit longer
um but i made oh beautiful beautiful
face there
i maintained that in in this film i
guess i made it 10 seconds most things
were divisible by five though i was
pretty specific about my cuts
um in this case i felt like it was
needed uh i know it's a cliche you're
not supposed to do it but because the
entire point of this
uh from my perspective is to show one
day
that spans one year and also one month
um
there are supposed to be 30 shots i
think i ended up having to remove a
couple because they
threw the lighting off um so i think it
might be 28 which
it's february whatever but that was the
idea
is it is a month a day and a year all at
once and i was like this is how i start
my day so i'm committing
to uh making this and this is the first
time that you see
my attempts to most of the time there
are some exceptions where i felt it was
needed
have the transitions be related to
movement and a big part of that is that
it generally makes people feel
uncomfortable or anxious
so this is movement upwards which moves
to
movement sideways um that shot actually
that specific shot took probably more
takes than anything else we shot
i kept uh you know i would sean who's
the cinematographer
set up the camera and then i would watch
it back and be like no it's too happy
or like the movement was wrong sometimes
it was too slow
or it was too miserable because the
start of the film is intentionally
pretty bright um yeah this one
we redid more times than any other
movement in the entire thing
which you probably wouldn't guess by
looking at it um then i think it's also
one that ended up being a little bit
shorter because the optimism of how long
i was staring at the window in the first
shot of this was just
was just off but that's movement that
goes into that movement both
headed in the left direction this shot
right here was actually originally
way later um it was moved to the start
again because of the lighting it is such
an important thing
for me in this that everything
progressively got darker
so this was originally supposed to be
like the kind of midday
of a later scene where you'd be like
getting your food out of the fridge
um i think you can see like a trash bag
here that should not be here at this
point in the progression because the
idea was that early in the film would be
very clean but i moved it because
the lighting it was also the hardest
shot for me to color grade i've not done
color grading quite to this capacity
before and because of the
light in the fridge uh it was a real
pain to get it to look the right kind of
blue pew but it is there
and i feel like it works connecticut all
ordering non-essential employees
so that one there um and this is
something i was really specific about
too that i think i spoke about on a
podcast last week
is a lot of framing that's a thing that
i said to again the cinematographer
director of photography cameraman sean
finnegan before we started working on
the project was
i want to be framed within frames as
much as possible um
and that is something that you know most
people probably don't notice but
it's something that i decided uh after
having seen the movie hereditary
actually was
it's one of my favorite movies it is a
horror movie but it's also kind of a
family drama and
uh you feel very uncomfortable or at
least i did often watching that movie
uh from inside a house or apartment and
i was trying to pinpoint
what specifically caused that funnily
enough i also know that that's a system
that was used in
uh detroit become human which does use
dp's or director of photography's
directors of photography um who worked
in hollywood
yes in some cases the first time working
on a game
where the characters who are supposed to
look oppressed is the phrase
are framed um so this is a really
specific thing that you will see
repeatedly i'll point it out but
that's one of the things that i told
sean from the jump was like hey we need
to shoot this all in one day
uh because i need to track the light it
has to be in order
so my shot lists were really specific
and i think we moved one or two things
around
the part where i shower was the last
thing we shot because it meant that i
got wet
um but yeah that was one of the go-to's
is like has to be one day
has to be framed within frames wherever
possible uh even though this shot is
still light
um the news clip here is obviously the
beginning of covid
uh the sound designer mark picked all of
the news bytes um
and did literally all of the sounds you
know we we gave him a lot of the room
tone so he had
access to a lot of it um and a lot of
just like the background noise i
actually don't know how he mixed it
entirely uh that's his job and he did a
great job of it but um
yeah he he picked the specific news
clips i just told him which ones to pick
and at which scenes i would in theory be
looking at the television
um as a way to only have one part where
i actually speak
uh which i felt was also important which
we will get to
but this is obviously beginning of
covered this shot i wasn't going to use
uh i liked it so much i'm so bad at
scrubbing through footage
to stay home yeah because there's
already the coffee pot being put down
this comes back to me just staring at it
and this was just a shot that sean liked
um i wasn't gonna use it narratively um
but
i when i was looking back through it i
was like yeah that's that's real pretty
so we used it it does have a stabilizer
on it which is the only [ __ ] i had to
use a stabilizer on which i hate a
little bit
um but the focus ball was just so nice
there that
that's one that i added in when we had
cut other stuff like there's a shot that
would be
in between those two where i like do my
hair and put makeup on
i had to get rid of it because the
lighting in the bathroom was just way
off
uh i i managed to color grade it okay
but it was just
like inconsistent with everything else
that
happens in this particular room that
goes straight from the bedroom into this
kind of living room space which again
is intentionally very clinical um
is supposed to just in the subtlest of
ways obviously i don't feel like it
commits to that 100
um commit to being a little bit hospital
like
that's kind of the idea um and that goes
with the theme of you know
the film opens up back here with
if you were curious this is a nebulizer
this is mine uh that's part of it and
that's an asthma and halo
so you know that's that's that is a
theme um that is
realistic about this is that i do in
fact
have asthma and uh did
have to be pretty careful uh about
staying indoors for a lot of last year
as a result of that obviously this year
too
um so that that is that is definitely a
thing that was supposed to be
sort of consistent across the board here
and this is another example of being
framed within a frame
we were very specific about that one um
which goes on between these shots
naturally this is the thing everyone
should notice it's getting messier
so i actually fun fact to keep that mess
happening
uh was keeping trash for like several
weeks
oh maybe not that long but i was keeping
trash
uh so that we didn't have to um
order uh a bunch of food in that day
um it was food that was actually eaten
and then put around the apartment
um obviously also some very bizarre
choices why would you ever put
uh a jumper on a tv why would you ever
put a jumper on a light
um but that stuff again didn't matter
because
i'm not really trying to tell a
narrative um i'm really trying to
express
a feeling so i you know things that when
working on the other short films that i
have planned to release which are
again way more narrative and character
focused i would never do again
um but for the purposes of this which
was a very experimental film
in a weird way again an expression of a
feeling
i don't feel like it's something that i
see that commonly i'm sure it's been
done to death i mean people told me when
they saw this that it was like the least
original concept of all time
uh that was probably the main criticism
i got but you know i've
not seen a single film that was based on
covert isolation
i have no doubt that plenty exist but
it's a
difficult thing to take as valuable
criticism when i had not seen any of
them
or even heard of them um even though in
my head i'm like of course people will
have made these like there's no way that
like students haven't been making these
for ages but i hadn't seen it so it's
like a thing that
an interesting criticism because i don't
know what i'm supposed to do with it
it's like well am i supposed to
not make something that i want to make
because other people have probably made
it
um though there were some fair
criticisms but you know regardless
moving on
stuff i would not do next time that i
was okay with in this instance
uh this one obviously the frame hang on
we go back to that
it gets more oppressive here um this is
intentionally brought down at that point
in time this is brought out
this is uh the contrast is obviously a
big shift here and i think
this might be the third shot that's
desaturated the desaturation starts here
right
so things start getting desaturated um
around this point and then this part is
intentionally
the only line of dialogue and also took
a long time to film because we wanted to
have me
again framed within the frame at the
very end here
but also a little bit brighter um the
saturation is back up
on this shot and it's the only time i
speak
the entire time um again there was
dialogue that i had written originally
but
things changed over time uh and i made
it this
this way because again something that i
just really resonated with was the idea
of
speaking to people through zoom through
streams through facetime which is what's
happening here
uh were the times where i felt the most
happy probably and i say that even as
someone who was really anti-social and
insular anyway so
this was a really specific choice the
intent there being that i'm speaking to
family that i am standing up
moving um even if the camera is still
still and
yeah saturation is back up for this shot
before starting to dip
a little more aggressively again um this
part right here
was also something that a film student
criticized me for
they said this is a huge editing mistake
this is embarrassing
uh because you're looking at the camera
i wasn't looking at the camera that was
a transitional choice
um so this is not me i mean my face
doesn't even get that far
uh don't look at the camera if that is
just another one to have movement so
if i looked to the left and then the
stand up is also to the left was the
idea again
um because i generally seeing a cut
halfway through a movement gives people
a little bit of a sense of discomfort
is sort of the point with that so this
one
yeah i did toy with having a doorbell
ring um
i think this shot was totally sean's
idea and also very difficult to execute
correctly
very cool having that that uh mirror
work which is a thing that he definitely
looks for
um i feel like you can see the
desaturation getting more intense here
so then this shot is the one that i feel
like i was the most
specific about um you know it's just the
idea of eating lunch
outside right and when we first sat down
to film this one sean
being someone who like really i told him
on the day when we were filming it like
i wanted to work with him because sean
can make anything look pretty uh he's
also a photographer
um i worked with him at ign and he shot
unboxings that he made look beautiful i
was like i know that
i can you can make anything look pretty
as the director it is my job to to like
be like okay here's how i want this
setup and here's why kind of thing
um and he for this scene i think was
originally like why don't we like shoot
you over the shoulder looking out to the
city
and i was like no it's going to be the
exact opposite i'm going to sit right
here on this balcony
in between all of this um
make sure that i'm really hunched over
that my shoulders are up like very very
very intentional with the posture on
this one
um and and yeah just make sure that i'm
framed within these frames almost like a
little bit of
a prison and it was really specific with
the lunchtime shot
um again this isn't based on my life but
it is
experiences that i'm pulling from which
is generally how most writing works
um is that the lunchtime is a thing that
i feel like
in the real world outside of isolation
was something that i would look forward
to
in this instance during the pandemic
lunch is
just being in an apartment and eating in
silence
that's really was my experience and that
was one thing that you know
at this point if this is lunchtime we've
had the the monotony of working in the
morning and
eating lunch by yourself it's just um
yeah something that i feel like
a lot of days lunchtime was a low point
for me um frankly i would say i worked
through most lunch breaks
uh but yeah this shot is intended to
feel like someone
caged um not being
able to access the world that is behind
them and kind of looming over them
especially as someone
uh with a series of chronic illnesses um
it's a very very very specific shot
that again like you know sean wanting to
film it from behind me and looking out
it was like of course that would look
beautiful and this probably
isn't as pretty it's you know me and
batman pajama pants that are super old
and
a fun house shirt that's slightly too
loose and a subway bag
um very weirdly eating a wrap
but it is very intentional
to fit with the tone and is also the
biggest drop in desaturation so
like this shot versus the previous shot
uh i think
this is the first time it dropped by 30
percent
so yeah this is a very pivotal one for
me and also why i made it
the thumbnail ultimately
it is a weird way to eat a wrap i also
was just candidly eating i was pretty
hungry by that point
that was another movement thing right
there is like a
intentionally the part where i move up
to push my hair back is the part where i
move up to
uh to push my face uh this is my least
favorite part of the entire short film
though this segment right here
is you know just supposed to be
frustration um
i don't feel like it necessarily sold
what i was trying to do very well this
is something i would have done
um but these three shots here
uh for sure my least favorite um and i
think a big part of that is that we
didn't keep the camera still
it was scripted to be the same thing as
before um
where you know it would be the camera in
the same spot more working through the
afternoon but like you know if i weren't
trying to stick to
311 and i weren't trying to stick to
uh having a certain amount of shots to
make up a month which
of course nobody else has noticed no
one's even pointed those things out
they're just for me just a creative
challenge i think i probably would have
cut these or replaced these in some way
if it all went filmed in one day
definitely my least favorite part that i
don't feel like it adds a whole lot in
this segment
um but this is another movement thing i
timed that one
to be actually [ __ ] ages the time of
me pushing my hair back
to getting the next hand to be the
headphones out like this
honestly took so
long and it's pretty close
like that getting that right it's
bizarrely long amount of time
um but yeah i kind of dislike those
three shots but
you know it is what it is
um yeah this part was where we would
have gone to the fridge
originally moved here for lighting
purposes
this is another shot that was sean's
choice he just really liked the
silhouette
um i wasn't gonna keep
the workout part twice but then i felt
like it also
worked because i think this one
that's back to kobe so hang on there is
an earlier shot that also has a news
report
in it this one one of these is supposed
to mention
um the blm
uh it's just quieter because it's off in
the background but yeah so
transition those two together
just the span of time we did have to
wait a while to film this one because
uh that was the first time we needed it
to really be dark so we're kind of
waiting till the lights came on in the
in the city there as well for that
but i like the way this turned out fun
fact to get the light on my face to move
it's actually just sean standing in the
background and doing this
like in front of a light which took a
while to get right as well
uh because initially it was like too
much or too little
so um yeah that did take a while to get
right to and
also my setup form is incorrect but it
looks better
there are a lot of things in film that
are completely wrong
but it looks better
um yeah this is intended to be dinner
time
some people did say nobody eats like
that but i was candidly eating
that was not posed this way specifically
uh the one thing i really did like about
this is the
the shadow movement on the face
naturally this was the last shot
of the day as i said before um
because then i would be wet so i had to
navigate around that i am actually
clothed
so i'm showering in clothes um
but this was also really hard to figure
out how we were going to do that i was
hoping
that the shower curtain would be thin
enough that you could see my silhouette
behind it and that we would do it that
way
we also played with like there being a
small gap between the shower and the
shower cut and where i would maybe
lean or something like that um but this
ended up being
the thing that was kind of the easiest
and made the most sense so
i shower after i work out climbing the
steps on the western side of the capitol
they have reached this is obviously
into january
these two are pretty specific to link as
well we're pretty careful
uh did take me a while to cry i'll be
honest about that
that was sort of difficult and the audio
cut there
that was all mark when he sent this to
me and i didn't know he was gonna do it
um i like got chills
i just thought that was so good when he
did it and i'm sure this is also
probably like a movie cliche
type thing um but i wanted to keep the
staring in the mirror shot because
again that is something that i feel like
is a very good expression of isolation
uh is the intent is just the only time
you really ever see two people in one
shot
it's the same one person outside of the
one where you grab the mask which is
similarly themed um as being
the idea that i would be going outside
um but really it's just a door or
whatever but
yeah but i like the way that this was
shot too that was shawn's decision i
would have had it just stay on the
camera but he chose to pan it and um
that yeah that was totally his call um
that one as well was mark not me
obviously
asthma inhaler in this part was me but
uh that uh
choice to cut audio there all mark these
last few shots were the first ones that
i wrote and were extremely specific
um that it was you know it's very much
in bed further out further out further
out black
um which i guess we can just play
through
just less light obviously as well uh as
as it consistently goes on
i do love the twitter refresh noise
there has the idea of it being kind of
some hub there was one more shot in here
that we had where you couldn't see me
and you could just see the city
uh but i felt like it was a little bit
distracting
um i ended up thinking that the light on
the face
going straight to complete black was a
better idea
and then you know the next 10 seconds is
entirely black
i love that it timed out that way that
the last shot is actually at 301
and then the next 10 seconds to get to
the 11 uh
pitch black um i felt strongly
about uh you know again having that
be the the progress i did toy
very very heavily debated this one for a
while of having the
first shot at the end again of me waking
up you know just to show the repetition
but having decided to commit to
the desaturation and the light it just
didn't work even when i desaturated it
and made it darker
it's just too bright um the exposure you
know i i did play with it quite a bit
but
ultimately decided against it so
yeah that's ultimately it um something
that was a very fun
sort of exercise in you know filmmaking
um something that was really restrictive
to sort of
make it more creative i'm sure a lot of
the stuff is like very pretentious to
hear someone say out loud oh well you
see i framed myself within frames or
whatever
uh but that is something that i just
really wanted to play with um
especially knowing like i had a huge
time constraint to make this it was only
two people or three people sorry
including mark who was just not on set
um but yeah i i don't think it's perfect
by any means but am happy
with what i think it does to convey what
i was trying to go for and of course it
being public
um now means it can mean to you whatever
you want it to mean
that's the way that these kind of things
work um i have had a tremendous amount
of people tell me they cried which
as someone trying to make something that
was intended to express a feeling is
like
the biggest compliment in the world
honestly um
so proud to have been able to have that
effect
especially with no music um and you know
without any
reason for you to get attached to the
character because i didn't develop the
character
uh i just developed a vessel
to show the emotion
effectively you know the next thing that
i've written that that
i hope that the world makes it easier to
shoot i really only could shoot this one
because again it only requires two
people while also being covered safe
um is like a drama comedy very character
focused very very very different
uh though i do absolutely love and
always have
any kind of film that takes place
largely in one room i am such a fan of
that
um and it would in theory do that i
am happy with a lot of what we did i
learned a lot uh the edit took a long
time and was really careful and i think
like i said the creative challenges of
trying to make shots often five seconds
or add up to five seconds so like one
was three and one was two or
ten seconds like really really specific
with a lot of that stuff
was just a fun challenge for me um not
trying to make an award-winning
blockbuster
um just trying to be consistent with
themes and
play with the idea of you know being a
director and of like what is the vision
and how am i expressing the vision and
how am i
you know committing to this this thing
as much as i possibly can and i do feel
like
that worked pretty well and hey
it's my first short film uh i feel like
i'm pretty happy with where we started
it's the first time i've ever done this
so a huge thank you to everyone
who left uh kind comments or the people
who felt like it resonated with them
it's it's a tremendous compliment to
have been able to have that effect on
anyone at all
thank you for sharing and um
yeah hopefully i can make another two
this year time permitting i
look forward to it it's a fun new
creative endeavor and i think i'll
hopefully be able to make bigger stuff
in the long run and i don't know where
this is going to take me but i expect it
will be kind of a consistent hobby where
it's like
when things can be a little bit bigger
maybe one a year type thing
um but yeah that's pretty much it
thank you all for watching i hope this
was at all interesting and not just
self-indulgent even if i had a fun time
talking about it
um because you know it was a very fun
creative expression
um and that is it for me today everyone
i will see you guys next time
bye